[Music]  ah  you brothers you could move mountains  without lifting a finger  minister malcolm x good news the chariot  is coming  who's that's right jim brown takes the  ball your record is going to stand the  test of time  all together  the entire city of miami is celebrating  i'm the new heavyweight champion of the  world and i don't even have a scratch on  my face  oh my goodness why am i so pretty  hey congratulations jim i could get used  to that  this movement that we are in is called a  struggle  because we are fighting for our lives  this ain't about civil rights  we have to be there for each other rich  all i gotta do is  [Music]  so  [Music]  you